au fil des ans,
Andy Spitzer a perdu beaucoup de
copines assez géniales hein
mais il y a une chose qu'il n'a jamais perdue
vierges ce qui a du sens maintenant Andy est
vierge ou pas ouais pourquoi porte
-t-il cette chemise en nitrate d'argent présente qu'est-ce que
tu portes un manteau de fourrure mec  si ce
sont tes mamelons, je vais raconter
une histoire sur la recherche de l'amour par
exemple les dents et le trouver je suis
enceinte haha ​​tu es très
enceinte et je me demande juste comment cela
s'est passé en un jour  je suis à moitié mexicain
vraiment une comédie de très mauvaises proportions
aurais-je ramassé la nuit dernière mcanalovin
c'est une bonne idée homme génial shimmy
classe de 2010 Chicka Chicka ya
mec pas question que nous soyons ce gars de la série
qui attrape les agresseurs qu'est-ce que tu
fais ici  Je suis en train d'enregistrer l'émission
whoa je ne suis pas un agresseur pouvez-vous m'entendre
maintenant restez assoiffé mes amis